y la extirpación de la vesícula biliar
denominada colecistectomía por lo
general se realiza ante la presencia de
cálculos biliares o inflamación de la
vesícula biliar los síntomas de
enfermedad de la vesícula biliar por lo
general consisten en dolor abdominal
intermitente en el cuadrante superior y
comúnmente se presentan cuando los
cálculos biliares obstruyen
temporalmente uno de los dos conductos
que llevan la bilis desde la vesícula
biliar al intestino si los cálculos no
pasan la vesícula biliar se puede
hinchar inflamar o infectar lo que puede
ocasionar síntomas más serios como
náuseas vómitos y fiebre
las técnicas laparoscópicas más
recientes requieren solo incisiones
mínimas en forma de ojo de cerradura y
el periodo de recuperación es mucho más
corto antes del procedimiento se
colocará una vía intravenosa y es
posible que se le suministre un sedante
para ayudarlo a relajarse la
colecistectomía laparoscópica se realiza
con anestesia general por lo tanto
estará dormido el tiempo que dure la
operación
esto relajara los músculos de la pared
abdominal dándole espacio al cirujano
para trabajar se insertará temporalmente
un tubo respiratorio por la boca y hacia
la garganta para ayudarlo a respirar
durante la operación es posible que
también tenga un tubo gástrico oral
colocado por la boca y en el estómago
para ayudar a drenar los fluidos que
allí se producen en la mayoría de los
casos el procedimiento lleva entre 30 y
60 minutos
para poder acceder a la vesícula biliar
y las estructuras de alrededor el
cirujano utilizará instrumentos
cortantes denominados trócares para
crear una serie de orificios pequeños o
puertos de entrada a través de la pared
abdominal
generalmente uno de estos puertos de
entrada se encuentra a nivel umbilical
luego se bombeará dióxido de carbono a
través de los puertos de entrada
umbilical para inflar el abdomen y así
poder visualizar su contenido más
fácilmente luego el cirujano insertará
en laparoscopia a través del puerto de
entrada umbilical y las imágenes de la
cámara se proyectan en un monitor de la
sala de operaciones
pasando otros instrumentos a través de
los diferentes puertos el cirujano
sujetará la vesícula biliar desprenderá
su arteria principal y conducto la
colocará en una bolsa para muestras y
retirará la bolsa a través de uno de los
puertos antes de retirar el laparoscopio
el cirujano observará la zona por última
vez en busca de sangrado u otro daño
al retirar el laparoscopio se deja en el
lugar una válvula del puerto por poco
tiempo para liberar todo el dióxido de
carbono del abdomen
finalmente las incisiones en forma de
ojo de cerradura se cierran con suturas
o grapas y se cubren con vendaje
después de la cirugía se retirará el
tubo gástrico oral y el respiratorio y
se lo trasladará al área de recuperación
para su monitoreo se le administrara
medicamento para el dolor según sea
necesario y progresará lentamente de una
dieta líquida a una blanda y de blanda a
sólida una vez que su sistema
gastrointestinal se recupere se le
retirará la vía intravenosa la mayoría
de los pacientes de colecistectomía
electiva son dados de alta dentro de las
24 horas los pacientes con vesículas
biliares infectadas pueden necesitar
permanecer en el hospital uno o dos días
más